The most common way to construct a hash table on a CPU works as follows.
So we have a bunch of buckets here, and we have a hash function h.
And this hash function takes a key and maps that key into one of those buckets.
So if the the hash function of the key k returns 0, h of k is 0,
then that key is associated with bucket 0.
If h of k is 1, then that key is associated with bucket 1 and so on.
Within a bucket, we store a bunch of items as a linked list, and this is called chaining.
So we might have multiple items in this bucket, multiple keys.
So key 12, key 29, key 123
all have a hash function that's equal to 1,
so they're placed in bucket 1, and we store them as this chained, linked list.
Then when we want to look up a key, we take that key.
We run it through the hash function
to get a particular value out of the hash function
that's going to refer us to a particular bucket, so we have this key.
It's going to return; oh, he's in bucket 1.
Then we will look through all these chained items
to find the key that we're looking for.